ballparking is a technique that helps us
to solve problems quickly instead of
trying to get a perfect result we make a
fast intelligent guess just like in
baseball to score we don't need to hit
the ball perfectly often we just need to
keep it inside the ballpark the
technique is useful in conversations and
is essential to passing certain tests to
watch this video most effectively grab a
pen and paper and try solving the
following two problems as we present
them just pause whenever you see this
sign
let's start easy what do you think is
the most popular food in the world could
it be Italian Japanese American fast
food or something else as it is
impossible to get an exact answer let's
look at what we maybe already know in
Italy there are around 50 million people
in Japan about a hundred million and in
North America about 500 million but in
China or in India that lives over a
billion people now we can use the
process of elimination and make a
ballpark estimate that Chinese and
Indian food is probably the most popular
try something a little harder imagine
that you were doing a complicated maths
test for something like the GMAT exam
then you might have just two minutes to
solve complex problems in your head
maybe something like the square root of
five times the square root of 24 plus
five divided by five plus two times the
square root of six then you're given
five multiple-choice answers
a B C D or E if we would try to solve it
we will probably run out of time
ballparking is now the only option you
can try it on your own
or do it with us
look at the equation let's look at the
first part the square root of 24 since
the square root of 24 is difficult to
calculate in your head think of a close
enough number to the square root of 24
that will be easier for you the square
root of 25 comes to mind to which the
answer is 5 let's now write down the new
simpler equation and then again even
simpler now what about the fraction it
looks hard but let's try
even if we don't know what five plus two
times the square root of six is we do
know that it's more than five so let's
write it again and just call the
denominator more than five and because 5
divided by anything larger than five
must be smaller than one let's write 25
plus less than one or the square root of
25 and that equals approximately five
let's now look at the options we were
given
look at the equation and each possible
choice
a is clear and doesn't look bad B is
five plus two times the square root of
six which is something like seven or
more that doesn't look right C is the
square root of something that comes out
to be three or less that's too small
what about D the square root of 120 we
don't know that but we do know that the
square root of a hundred is ten let's
just write ten or more that looks too
high last there is e five divided by two
times the square root of six now for two
times the square root of six let's just
write more than two and five divided by
something that's more than two also
looks too small now we can use the
process of elimination and cross out all
the wrong answers to see what's left a
it is
now it's your turn tribal barking the
amount of views that you think this
video will have by the end of this year
and when your favorite sprouts gift on
patreon.com slash sprouts we will count
all entries submitted by August the 31st
and announce the winner on the 1st of
January to join just leave your ballpark
figure in the comments below and if you
want tell us how you did it those of you
who post later than August the 31st will
enter next year's round of sprouts
ballpark Awards good luck
you